BRAZIL'S PRESIDENT BOLSONARO
KICKED OFF HIS REELECTION
CAMPAIGN JUST HOURS AGO.
HE IS AFRAID TO MAKE IT TO THE
RUNOFF AND SO IT IS LUIZ DA
SILVA WHO LED THE COUNTRY FROM
2003 TO 2010.
SO FAR, THE LEFT HIS FOREIGN
PRESIDENT IS AHEAD OF THE
FAR-RIGHT INCUMBENT IN THE
POLLS.
HIS LEAD HAS FALLEN IN THE PAST
FEW MONTHS.
ONE THING IS FOR CERTAIN.
THIS IS SHAPING UP TO BE ONE OF
THE MOST DIVISIVE PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGNS IN BRAZILIAN HISTORY.
THE PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN HAS
ONLY JUST STARTED.
BUT MANY ARE ALREADY AFRAID OF
HOW IT MAY END.
WITH HUNDREDS MARCHING ON THE
CAPITAL IN DEFENSIVE BRAZILIAN
DEMOCRACY.
>> IT HAPPENED IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA AND IT IS
HAPPENING IN THIS COUNTRY.
THE CONSTANT ATTACK AGAINST OUR
DEMOCRATIC INSTITUTIONS.
>> THE MAN THEY SAY IS STOKING
THIS FEAR IS BEING INCUMBENT
PRESIDENT HIMSELF.
WHO HAS BEEN REPEATING BASELESS
ATTACKS ON THE ELECTORAL
SYSTEM.
PROMISING HIS OPPONENTS A TOUGH
FIGHT HAS LAUNCHED HIS BID FOR
A SECOND TERM.
>> WE ARE THE MAJORITY.
WE ARE THE GOOD ONES AND WE ARE
WILLING TO FIGHT FOR OUR
FREEDOM AND OUR HOMELAND.
>> FOR OVER A YEAR, BOLSONARO
HAS BEEN CRITICIZING ELECTRONIC
VOTING.
SAYING WITHOUT ANY AVOIDANCE,
THAT IT'S OPEN TO FRAUD.
HE'S CALLED FOR PRINTED BALLOTS
TO BE USED ALONGSIDE ELECTRONIC
ONES.
AND IN DOING SO, HAS HIS EYES
FULLY ON THE PRESIDENTIAL
PRIZE.
>> I HAVE THREE ALTERNATIVES
FOR MY FUTURE.
JAIL, DEATH, OR VICTORY.
>> IT'S A RHETORIC ABOUT BOTH
HIS STAUNCHEST SUPPORTERS AND
PARTY FULLY BACK.
>> WE BELIEVE PRESIDENT
BOLSONARO'S CRITICISM TO BE
VALID.
WE HAVE A PORTION OF SOCIETY,
AROUND 15 TO 20%, WHICH ALSO
DOUBTS ELECTRONIC BALLOTS.
>> BUT WHAT HIS PARTY SAYS THE
QUEST FOR TRANSPARENCY, MANY
ARGUE IS DANGEROUS RHETORIC.
EVEN PROMPTING CIVIL SOCIETY
FIGURES TO SIGN A LETTER FOR
DEMOCRACY.
A MANIFESTO IN DEFENSIVE
DEMOCRATIC VALUES.
JUDGE --
WAS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
SUPREME ELECTORAL COURT UNTIL
THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR.
HELPING ORGANIZE ELECTIONS AT A
NATIONAL LEVEL.
HE TELLS ME THE NEED FOR A
MANIFESTO SHOWS SOME ARE AFRAID
FOR BRAZILIAN DEMOCRACY.
>> THE NUMBER OF TIMES THAT
PEOPLE ASK ME IF I FEAR A COUP
D'ÉTAT MEANS THAT THERE ARE
SOMETHING STRANGE GOING ON.
>> IN FOR THE MAN VYING FOR
BOLSONARO'S JOB, THE PERCEIVED
THREAT OF DEMOCRACY HAS A CLEAR
ORIGIN.
>> EVERY DAY, HE OFFENSE THE
SUPREME COURT.
EVERY DAY, HE OFFENDS AN
ELECTORAL JUSTICE AND EVERY DAY
HE OFFENDS THOSE WHO DO NOT
LIKE HIM.
>> RETURNING TO THE BALLOT FOR
MORE THAN A DECADE ON THE
SIDELINES AND AFTER BEING
CONVICTED FOR CORRUPTION, THE
FORMER PRESIDENT AND
BOLSONARO'S MAIN OPPONENT SAYS
HE WANTS TO FOCUS ON BRAZIL'S
POST PANDEMIC RECOVERY.
>> I AM OLDER BUT I AM MUCH
BETTER.
WITH MUCH MORE STRENGTH AND
WITH MUCH MORE COURAGE TO MAKE
THIS COUNTRY SUCCEED.
>> BRAZIL'S SUCCESS IS
DEPENDENT ON A SMOOTH ELECTION.
DESPITE THE RHETORIC FROM
POPULISTS PRESIDENT BOLSONARO,
A JUDGE --
TELLS ME THE ELECTORAL SYSTEM
IS STRONG ENOUGH TO HANDLE THE
CRITICISM.
AND SAYS THERE ARE SOME GOOD
NEWS.
>> AROUND 80% OF THE POPULATION
TRUSTS THE SYSTEM DESPITE ALL
THE ATTACKS WE'VE BEEN
SUFFERING.
OUR ROLE IS TO ASHORE THAT
WEATHER --
WHOEVER WINS IN THE OCTOBER
ELECTIONS WILL BE INAUGURATED
ON JANUARY THE 1ST AND THE PLAN
IS GOING TO LAND SAFELY.
>> STILL AS THE CAMPAIGN KICKS
OFF AND THE RHETORIC HARDENS,
POLITICAL TURBULENCE CANNOT BE
RULED OUT.
AND THE RIGHT COULD STILL BE
BUMPY.
>> PRESIDENT BOLSONARO DENIES
HE HAS ANY INTENTION OF
CARRYING OUT A COUP.
EVEN THOUGH HE HAS HINTED
MULTIPLE TIMES HE WOULD NOT
STEP DOWN IN THE EVENT HE IS
DEFEATED AS YOU HEARD THERE.
I WANT TO BRING IN BRAZILIAN
JOURNALIST --
WHO JOINS ME NOW.
PATRICIA, REALLY GOOD HAVE YOU
ON THE SHOW.
THE CAMPAIGN AS WE'VE SEEN IS
OFFICIALLY IN FULL SWING.
I WANT TO SHOW OUR VIEWERS SOME
SCENES WE'RE SEEING NOW FROM
SOME --
OF THE STATE OF SÃO PAULO.
THERE WE ARE SEEING LIVE IMAGES
OF LULA, --
OFFICIALLY LAUNCHING HIS
ELECTION CAMPAIGN AT A
VOLKSWAGEN PLANT I BELIEVE.
REALLY, PATRICIA, WE ARE SEEING
REALLY LULA STILL LEADING IN
TERMS OF POLLING BUT THE CAP IS
NARROWING.
HOW IS BOLSONARO GAINING GROUND
YOU THINK IN YOUR VIEW?
>> THE RACE IS MUCH TIGHTER
THAN WE IMAGINED IT WAS GOING
TO BE.
AND I THINK MAINLY THERE IS A
LOT OF THIS INFORMATION
CIRCULATING MAINLY TOWARDS
EVANGELICAL VOTERS.
HE'S GAINING A LOT OF TERRAIN
AROUND EVANGELICAL VOTERS AND
WOMEN.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF
RECALCULATION AMONG THE
CAMPAIGNS OF HOW TO PROCEED
FROM NOW ON.
>> ONE OF THE ALLEGATIONS I'VE
SEEN OR THE FAKE NEWS LET'S SAY
THAT I HAVE HEARD IN THE LAST
HOURS FROM THE BOLSONARO
MACHINE IS THAT LULA FOR
EXAMPLE WILL CLOSE ALL THE
EVANGELICAL CHURCHES IN BRAZIL.
OF COURSE, FOR OUR VIEWERS,
JUST GOOD UNDERSTANDING HERE,
THIS IS THE BEEF BIBLES AND
BULLETS KIND OF FACE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK, HOW DO YOU
THINK THAT BOLSONARO IS GOING
TO RAMP UP THIS FAKE NEWS
MACHINE AS WE HEAD UP TO
OCTOBER THE 2ND?
>> I THINK HE HAS STRUCTURED
THIS INFORMATION STRUCTURE THAT
HAS BEEN IN PLACE SINCE 2018.
THEY HAVE THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF WHATSAPP AND
TELEGRAM GROUPS WHERE A LOT OF
DISINFORMATION OR JUST
PROPAGANDA IS BEING
DISSEMINATED.
SO FOR THE OTHER PARTIES AND
EVEN THE ELECTORAL --
COUNTER THIS INFORMATION IS
VERY COMPLEX BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE SUCH A STRUCTURE AND IT'S
VERY HARD TO MAKE QUALITY
INFORMATION OR FACT-CHECKING GO
VIRAL.
>> WOULD I'VE BEEN HEARING FOR
THE PAST YEAR OR SO FOR SEVERAL
PEOPLE ACTUALLY --
ECHELONS OF SIGHT IN BRAZIL IS
THERE VERY MUCH FEARFUL OF AN
ATTACK ON DEMOCRACY.
ESPECIALLY AS BOLSONARO CALLS
INTO QUESTION AS WE HEARD THERE
THE KIND OF ELECTRONIC VOTING
SYSTEM.
HOW REAL IS THIS --
THE FEAR THAT BOLSONARO WON'T
ACCEPT A FEAT IF HE DOES LOSE?
>> IT'S VERY REAL.
UNFORTUNATELY AND IT'S VERY
UNFORTUNATE --
THEY'RE DISCUSSING AT ALMOST 45
YEARS AFTER THE END OF THE
MILITARY DICTATORSHIP.
HE'S BEEN SOWING DOUBTS ABOUT
THE ELECTORAL PROCESS AND THERE
--
ACTUALLY RIGHT AFTER JANUARY
SIX, THE CAPITAL INVASION IN
THE U.S., HE SAID THAT IF WE
DID NOT CHANGE OUR SYSTEM, IT
WOULD BE MUCH WORSE THAN WHAT
HAPPENED THERE IN THE U.S..
SO I HAVE NO DOUBTS THAT WE
HAVE A SLOW MOTION COUP GOING
ON.
HE'S DOING THIS PREEMPTIVELY IN
CASE HE LOSES.
HE'S NOT GOING TO ACCEPT THE
RESULTS.
>> THIS IS VERY WORRYING
INDEED.
IF YOU THINK THAT WE COULD BE
SEEING SOMETHING LIKE WE SAW IN
JANUARY 6TH CAPITOL, THAT'S
VERY WORRYING INDEED.
WHERE DOES MILITARY PARTITION
STAND ON THIS?
>> THAT'S THE BIG QUESTION.
WE'RE NOT SURE IF THE MILITARY
WOULD SUPPORT A COUP D'ÉTAT.
AS WE SAW IN THE CAPITAL
INVASION --
WE COULD HAVE SOCIAL UNREST AND
IN BRAZIL SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF BOLSONARO'S ADMINISTRATION,
WE HAVE 1 MILLION MORE GUN
CIRCULATING IN THE COUNTRY.
WE HAVE A SITUATION THAT HE
REFUSED TO RESULT IN HINDSIGHT
SUPPORTERS TO GO TO THE STREETS
AND PEOPLE HAVE LOTS MORE --
CIRCULATING SO WE DON'T KNOW IF
HE WOULD --
IF THE MILITARY WOULD SUPPORT
HIM.
BUT EVEN IF HE'S NOT, WHICH IS
VERY LIKELY THAT HE WOULD NOT
BE SUCCESSFUL.
WE COULD HAVE SOME VIOLENCE, A
LOT OF VIOLENCE.
>> LOOK, WE'VE MENTIONED
TALKING ABOUT BOLSONARO BUT OF
COURSE WE HAVEN'T MENTIONED
LULA.
THAT'S BECAUSE HE'S A VERY
WELL-KNOWN FACE FOR OUR
VIEWERS.
SOME ARE STILL PRETTY UNEASY
ABOUT HIS RETURN.
HE'S A BIT OF A TARNISH ICON.
CAN HE APPEALED TO A DIVIDED
BRAZIL?
CAN HE UNITE BRAZIL?
>> THERE IS THE ANTI WORKERS
PARTY.
PARTS OF THE POPULATION IS VERY
STORM BECAUSE ALL THE
CORRUPTION CANDLES SHATTERING
THE WORKERS PARTY
ADMINISTRATIONS, PEOPLE
REMEMBER THIS VERY VIVIDLY.
THAT'S WHY THEY VOTED FOR
BOLSONARO 2018 BECAUSE THEY
WERE REALISTIC OF ALL THE
CORRUPTION SCANDALS.
AND THE SAME TIME, PEOPLE ALSO
REMEMBER THAT IN THE FIRST
SULLIVAN EXTRADITION WE HAD
INCOME DISTRIBUTION AND PEOPLE
HAD MORE MONEY TO SPEND ON FOOD
AND NOW IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
WITH FOOD INFLATION AND
UNEMPLOYMENT.
THE LOOK CAN PAIN IS BETTING
THAT PEOPLE ARE GOING TO WEIGH
THESE TWO THINGS.
THE ECONOMY AND HOW MUCH MONEY
THEY USED TO HAVE DURING THE
LOVELY YEARS.
AGAINST CORRUPTION SCANDALS IN
ALL OF THE EVERYTHING THAT
HAPPENED WHEN HE WAS IN PRISON.
AND THAT THEY'RE GOING TO VOTE
FOR LULA BECAUSE OF THIS
MEMORIES OF GOOD TIMES.
>> AND SOME REMEMBER THE GOLDEN
YEARS AND WITH INFLATION ON ONE
ALMOST 12% I THINK MANY PEOPLE
JUST WANT TO PUT FOOD ON THE
TABLE RIGHT NOW.
PATRICIA --
ALWAYS GREAT TO GO ON YOUR
SHOW.
THANKS, PATRICIA.